you may have heard that chinese stocks
have taken a beating this year when i
heard this i assumed that tiny stocks
were down 10 15 maybe 20
but a couple of days ago i checked out
the graphs of the most popular chinese
stocks and i was blown away alibaba is
down 50 since last october tencent is
down 43 since last february and jd.com
is down 40 since february
it's not just individual companies
either the nasdaq golden dragon china
index for instance is a compilation of
the 98 biggest chinese companies traded
on u.s markets and the entire index
itself is down 52 since just february
this means that this is the largest
crash experienced by chinese stocks
since the 2008 financial crisis
meanwhile if you're just looking at the
american stock market you wouldn't even
know that such a crisis was going on as
the s p 500 hasn't even pulled back five
percent since last october so why are
chinese stocks getting massacred
the most obvious reason on the surface
seems to be increasing american
regulation
since the beginning of the year the u.s
government has made their intent to
crack down on chinese talks extremely
clear for instance in march the sec
adopted a new law called the holding
foreign companies accountable act this
law gives the sec the power to de-list
foreign companies from the u.s stock
market if they don't comply with
auditing requirements
this isn't just specific to chinese
stocks but chinese stocks were obviously
the biggest target
aside from required auditing the sec
mandated that chinese companies must
identify all of the ccp members that are
on the boards of the companies now you
might be thinking that these regulations
are a bit overboard and that these
policies are driven more by politics as
opposed to an actual concern
while that is partially true the threat
of accounting fraud can't be completely
dismissed
luck and coffee for instance was an up
and coming chinese coffee company
similar to starbucks they had blowout
after blowout earnings but eventually
the sec determined that it was too good
to be true
between april of 2019 and january of
2020 luck and coffee overstated their
revenues by at least 300 million dollars
this earned luck and coffee a 180
million dollar fine followed up by
delisting from the u.s stock market this
isn't a rare occurrence either almost
every year a tiny startup will fudge
their numbers and pull a quick one on
american investors while this is a shame
these companies aren't the real threat
in most cases their frauds are easily
visible to experts and the companies
themselves usually give in after they've
made their money the bigger companies
like alibaba and tension however are
suspected to have much more elaborate
schemes that can't be easily detected as
you would have guessed though the
chinese have no intention of cooperating
with american regulation
instead they've decided to fire back
with their own regulation on u.s stocks
until now none of this has led to any
serious action but as tensions escalate
many investors have decided to get out
before things actually get ugly aside
from the delisting fears china
themselves have been cracking down on
chinese companies this might sound a bit
weird if china themselves agreed that
more regulation is needed against their
own companies why aren't they accepting
american regulation
wouldn't another set of eyes just
improve the chances of catching
something nefarious
well the thing to keep in mind is that
china is a communist country and they
truly believe in socialist ideologies in
recent decades they have allowed for a
free market economy as this is really
the only way to stay up to speed with
western countries don't let this fool
you though the ccp is extremely keen on
maintaining control over the market and
whenever they see chinese companies and
individuals overstep their bounds the
ccp will crack down the ccp doesn't
really care if alibaba fudges numbers or
performs insider trading or anything
like that and that's why they don't care
about american regulation efforts but
they do care if alibaba is threatening
the power and control of the ccp
and over the past year the ccp has
determined that chinese tech
billionaires are indeed threatening
their power
the biggest indication of this was
likely jack moss quote-unquote
controversial speech late last year in
november of 2020 jack ma the founder of
alibaba made a speech in which he
criticized the chinese financial system
jack was actually being extremely
careful and made sure to preface his
critique by saying that he might be
wrong and that his word shouldn't be
taken too seriously
the ccp however took it pretty seriously
and jack ma would disappear for three
months i think this was really the
turning point jack speech made it clear
to the ccp that they gave billionaires
way too much freedom and ever since
china has been working on showing who's
truly in control
ironically this entails destroying their
own companies to put them in their place
one example of this crackdown is diddy
global diddy is basically the chinese
uber and they just went public in june
at 14 per share
after dd's ipo the ccp straight up
banned new users from downloading the
app in china there's also reports
suggesting that the tcp is considering
de-listing ditty and encouraging
citizens to use a state-owned right-hand
service
this is actually hilarious the ccp is
like americans don't worry about
de-listing our companies we'll do it
ourselves as you would guess dd stock is
down 54 since then
one harvard professor is actually
suggesting that the ccp wants the stock
to crash this way rich ccp officials can
buy up all their shares and take the
company private at super low prices
in other scenarios the ccp has banned
the ipo itself as is the case with jack
ma's ant group
aside from direct bans the ccp has also
swamped the top tech companies with a
plethora of lawsuits and litigation
in april the ccp hit alibaba with the
record 2.8 billion anti-trust fine they
also dished out a 1.5 billion antitrust
fine detention
regulators also gave other chinese tech
giants including bike dance baidu and
jd.com a stern warning that they better
watch what they're doing if they don't
want to end up like alibaba and tenchent
anyway the third factor driving down
chinese stock prices is china's economic
policy the fed has been printing money
like a madman and this has been the same
case around the world
since the start of the pandemic the us
has released 5.2 trillion dollars worth
of fiscal stimulus and it looks like the
fed is just starting to talk about
tapering
in china however they aren't just
talking about it they're already doing
it
in fact they started tapering their bond
sales at the beginning of the year
this might not sound like a big deal
tapering technically does mean the
economy is recovering well and that
government stimulus is no longer needed
nonetheless the market likes to throw a
tan trauma every time monetary policy is
tightened despite how obvious or
transparent the tightening was
and that brings us into the next factor
killing chinese stocks and that's
extreme valuations if you've been
following the american stock market you
would know that stocks have recently
been unstoppable stocks are arguably
overvalued and even in bubble territory
according to many of the most respected
fundamental indicators the schiller p e
ratio suggests that we're above great
depression levels and nearly at dot-com
levels similarly the buffet indicator
suggests that we are strongly overvalued
right now with the stock market boasting
a value that's 138 higher than the u.s
gdp
and if you think u.s stocks are out of
control you haven't taken a look at
chinese stocks during the pandemic the s
p 500 first dropped a little over 30
before rallying 92 within just 18 months
meanwhile the nasdaq golden dragon china
index only dropped 23 before rallying
141 within just 12 months keep in mind
that markets generally only grow 8 per
year so all these numbers are
unprecedented with that being said it
was just a matter of time until
something pushed these evaluations over
the edge and back down to reality and
that brings me into the biggest factor
pushing down chinese stocks and that's
market manipulation everything we've
outlined so far is absolutely valid and
something you should definitely consider
if you're going to invest into chinese
stocks
at the end of the day though there's
only one group that controls the big
movements within the stock market and
that's smart money this includes the big
market makers and hedge funds in the us
as well as the big financial
institutions in china along with the ccp
i wouldn't exactly say that these guys
are smart but they do have a crop ton of
money meaning that they can move markets
concerns regarding chinese accounting
and the listing tensions aren't anything
new cracking down on the chinese was one
of trump's biggest campaign promises way
back in 2015 and 2016. yet the market
did not care up until this year
this does not mean that the concerns are
invalid
but rather that the concerns only matter
when smart money says it matters here's
the thing the big players need liquidity
to actually get in and get out of the
market if they're selling 100 billion
worth of stocks they need someone to buy
100 billion worth of stocks and vice
versa and the way they get a bunch of
people to take the other side of the
trade is by creating extreme sentiments
in the market
for instance they might run up stocks
beyond belief just like they did last
year an index moving 141 within 12
months is ludicrous and the only reason
that happened is because smart money was
trying to bait retail investors into
chinese stocks by creating fomo or the
fear of missing out
but just as all the retailers bought in
smart money used the increased interest
to offload all of their positions
similarly as everyone sells their
positions smart money uses the increased
fear to buy the crash does that mean
that you should buy right now
not necessarily
just because the nasdaq golden dragon
china index is down 50
does not mean that this is the bottom
in the dot-com crash the u.s nasdaq 100
crashed 84 percent before bottoming out
study after study has shown that it's
basically impossible to time the market
unless of course your smart money or
have insider knowledge but the bottom
line is that smart money decided at the
start of this year that it was time to
get out and they used the listing fears
and us china tensions to stage their
exit
we might have seen some more support if
the ccp was interested in keeping stocks
high
but they were also on board with killing
valuations to teach the billionaires a
lesson
and this created the perfect storm that
massacred us listed chinese stocks
were you guys aware of this massive bear
market in the background comment that
down below
also drop a like if you can't wait to
see american stocks finally cool down as
well
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]